what's up everyone james murphy here from
mcoding, back with another video on python
weirdness. do you know what the comma equals
operator does in python? if you know the answer
to this trick question, let me know down below
in the comments, otherwise here are some choices.
in this situation x is one,
y is the list containing two,
and we're looking at x comma equals y.
afterwards we're printing out the value of x, so
is x the integer one? is x the integer two?
is x the singleton list containing one?
is x the tuple containing one and list of two?
or is this just a syntax error?
pause the video now if you need
some time to think about it.
all right done thinking
about it? so do you know what
the comma equals operator does?
let's find out by running it.
x gets the value 2. did you get it right?
well if you're like me then you probably
thought this was just a syntax error.
when i first saw this in a real code base,
i thought it was a syntax error and maybe that i
accidentally put the comma in myself. well that's
not true, as you can see this does something. so
if you're not sure about why this printed out two,
let's look at a simpler example. but first let me
give you a hint. i'll run my code formatter on it.
did you see what happened? here let me do
it again. ready format. it moved the comma.
do you know the answer now? if not let's just go
through it. here is a simpler example. suppose
we have a function, you know do
something, and x is 1 and y is 2.
then we can say x comma y equals y comma x.
what this syntax does is it will swap
the values of x and y. it's kind of
doing a little bit of pattern matching. let
me put in some unnecessary parentheses here.
it's kind of saying look at this pattern
on the left: x comma y, and try to extract
out values for x and y based off of what's on
the right hand side where you see y comma x.
in this case it kind of makes sense
that it would swap the values of x and y
because i would say, well matching the pattern
x should be the thing inside the tuple which
is at the zeroth index so that's y, and y
should be the thing which is inside the tuple
at the first index, which is x. so afterwards x is
equal to what y was and y is equal to what x was.
well this would work just as well
if this was a list or any other
iterable with two elements in it. and here's where
we see our previous example x comma equals y.
if you have a list of just one thing or a
tuple of just one thing the syntax looks a
little different. so suppose x was like this,
a tuple of one thing in python gives you
the following syntax. you need to have this extra
trailing comma after the single element in the
tuple because otherwise it just looks like you
parenthesized x, and we don't want parentheses
to be creating tuples unless you really meant
to. so in this case if you want the left hand
side to be a tuple you need to put that comma
in. but these parentheses are still optional,
so now do you see why x comma equals something
gives you the value that it did before?
well our previous case looked like
this: y was 2 and we just said x
comma equals y so now y here is
just like we're putting two in.
so it's saying pattern match this tuple
of one thing with this list of one thing.
that's why x gets the value two at the
end of it. make sense now? is there any
real case where you might want to use this
syntax? admittedly if you're using this syntax
you might be in a gray area. at the very
least absolutely do not format it this way.
put the spaces in the right place otherwise
you're just going to confuse people.
so i have come up with one case where it might
actually, you know, make sense to have something
like this. let's suppose that i have two sets
and i know that their intersection has only one
element. so just for demonstration purposes let's
say that we have a list of primes you know 2 3 5
7 11. and we have a list of evens which is 2 4 6
8 10. let me actually make these sets not lists,
now i know that the set of evens and
the set of primes only has one thing in
common and that's two. so i could say x comma
equals (with the correct spacing of course)
primes dot intersect intersection
with the evens, and then print x.
so in this case if i call do something
now we see that again it prints out two
so that's one case where if you know ahead of time
that there's only one thing in the right hand side
then you might actually want
to use this comma equal syntax
instead of having a temporary variable. you
know intersection equals this, and then x equals
intersection dot pop to get the one element out.
there you have it that's the
comma equals "operator" in python
hey thanks for watching again, if you like the
video remember to like comment and subscribe.
also i offer online python courses so if
you would like to learn python from me,
then go ahead and drop your contact
info at the link in the description,
and i'll let you know when online
python courses are available.